ja mich bewegt einerseits ich will noch
mal darauf aufmerksam machen dass
kriegerische Auseinandersetzungen nicht
nur die Stunde von Militär sind oder von
Politikern sondern auch die Stunde der
Nachrichtendienste Nachrichtendienste
bringen die Informationen die man
braucht auf dem Gefechtsfeld aber auch
für die Diplomatie oder für den
Informationskrieg und Nachrichtendienste
halten auch Kontakte für Verhandlungen
und Verhandlungen ist mein Stichwort für
die Ukraine ich glaube wir müssen
einfach feststellen dieser Krieg
eskaliert in vielen kleinen Schritten
wenn wir uns zurückschauen wie hat er
begonnen und wo stehen wir heute wie hat
sich das ausgeweitet und das will ich
gar nicht nur an den Waffenlieferungen
festmachen sondern insgesamt wie hat
sich das ausgeweitet dann stellen wir
fest stetig aber sicher eskaliert dieser
Konflikt und dann stellt sich die Frage
wie soll er denn Enden ich kenne kein
vernünftiges Szenario wie dieser Krieg
beendet werden kann für mich ist
jedenfalls kein vernünftiges Szenario
dass er militärisch beendet wird mit der
Niederlage ein oder mit der Niederlage
des anderen eine Niederlage der Russen
würden die Russen so nicht hinnehmen und
da bin ich ganz sicher bei ronsheimer da
haben wir die große Gefahr des Einsatzes
einer Atomwaffe einer taktischen
Atomwaffe eine Niederlage der Ukraine
wollen wir nicht hinnehmen und wir haben
die große Gefahr wie reagiert der Westen
wird er noch mehr hineingezogen ich bin
der Meinung wir dürfen uns von der
Ukraine nicht instrumentalisieren lassen
die Ukraine hat das große Ziel zu
gewinnen das verstehe ich ich will sie
auch unterstützen aber sie hat auch das
Ziel den Westen mit hineinzuziehen weil
das viel besser für die Ausgangsposition
ist dann müssen wir ehrlich aufpassen
und wenn wir etwas machen wollen dann
glaube ich ist es jetzt aktiv dafür
einzutreten dass es einen
Waffenstillstand gibt einen
Waffenstillstand der die Basis für
Verhandlungen ist und Verhandlungen kann
man sich vieler vielfach vorstellen ich
bin ganz sicher die Russen werden
verhandeln wollen und ich bin noch ganz
sicher bei nötigem Druck wenn die
Ukrainer verhandeln wollen und wie eine
solche Verhandlungslösung aussieht
können wir uns ja gleich mal drüber
unterhalten aber schön gleich ich habe
aufgehört als Bürgerin am Anfang ihrer
These mit Blick auf den
Bundesnachrichtendienst kann es denn
sein dass schon Gespräche oder
Informationen hinter den Kulissen laufen
und man schon näher an Verhandlungen ist
als wie das wissen also die
Nachrichtendienste verhandeln in solchen
Fragen nicht sondern die schaffen die
schaffen die Basis dieser Verhandlungen
führen ja sie halten die den Kontakte
weil sie sagen lass uns mal treffen wenn
jetzt unsere Politiker sich austauschen
wollen ohne dass sie es über die
Bild-Zeitung machen wollen sondern in
Geheimverhandlungen und dann muss das ja
irgendwie organisiert werden das ist die
Stunde der Nachrichtendienste und da
könnte auch schon viele Bewegungen sein
das könnte uns Herr Felgen treu am
besten darlegen also
da frage ich sie ist natürlich Herr
Felgentreu wissen vielleicht die
Nachrichtendienste teilweise mehr als
die Politiker
das will ich schwer hoffen also
jedenfalls habe ich für mich als in
meiner Rolle als als
Verteidigungspolitiker Informationen
brauchte mich an die Nachrichtendienste
gewandt in der Hoffnung sie dort zu
finden ja ich kann jetzt nicht über
alles berichten was ich dadurch auf
diesem Wege erfahren habe aber ich gehe
schon davon aus dass die
Nachrichtendienste werden zumindest mehr
wissen als
die die die die durchschnittlichen
Abgeordneten des Bundestages und so
sollte es auch sein und man sollte dann
eben als Abgeordneter versuchen diese
Informationen abzurufen damit man
tragfähige politische Entscheidungen
treffen kann ja aber was Schindler was
Sie gesagt haben ich sehe dann
Widerspruch in sich wenn sie sagen sie
wollen einerseits nicht die Niederlage
Russland sie wollen aber anderers auch
nicht die Niederlage der Ukraine bzw
wieder den Sieg der einen auf der
anderen Seite und deswegen wollen sie
jetzt einen Waffenstillstand aus meiner
Sicht ist vollkommen klar ein
Waffenstillstand jetzt
ist ein Etappensieg im Rahmen einer
Salamitaktik der russischen Seite der
erste dieser Krieg begann nicht im
Februar 2022 er begann im März glaube
ich 2014 damals wurde die erste Scheibe
von der Salami abgeschnitten nämlich der
Don Bass und die und die Krim und wenn
wir jetzt einen Waffenstillstand hätten
dann hätten wir die zweite Scheibe von
der Salami und zwar eine ziemlich dicke
Scheibe und das wäre bloß das
Aufmarschgebiet um dann die dritte
Scheibe Angriff zu nehmen mir wäre das
nicht mehr erreichen Sie durch einen
Waffenstillstand heute als der Ukraine
militärisch ganz schlecht ging in der
Anfangsphase war die Ukraine doch bereit
ein Waffenstillstand zu schließen so und
jetzt ist die Ukraine militärisch
gut dabei also sie Obsidian und dem im
Norden dann geht plötzlich ein
Waffenstillstand nicht also diesen
Widerspruch den sehe ich allerdings auch
und ich glaube
wenn wir eine Güte Abwägung machen
Salami Taktik russischer Sieg tappensieg
und auf der anderen Seite sehen wie
viele Menschen kommen tagtäglich in der
Ukraine um wie viel Leid bringt jeden
Tag dieser Krieg und das nicht nur für
die Ukraine sondern jetzt manchmal das
große Fass auf für die gesamte Welt die
Weltwirtschaft leidet darunter nicht nur
unter den Sanktionen sondern insgesamt
ist ja das ganze runterfahren der
Weltwirtschaft ursprünglich auch auf
diesen Ukraine Krieg zurückzuführen die
Migrationsfrage habe ich noch gar nicht
gestellt und und das ist ja ein eine
scharniert sind mehr Menschen gekommen
als 2015 also das bedeutet doch zu sagen
wir können den Russen keinen Etappen sie
gönnen und lassen aber zu dass alles
dieses Elend und dieses Unrecht was
geschieht weil Tag für Tag weiterläuft
das finde ich und da bin ich bei ihrer
These das finde ich so erschreckend für
Deutschland wo wir doch früher uns mal
so
Friedenspolitik empfunden haben und da
frage ich mich was ist in dieser
Gesellschaft passiert dass wir plötzlich
diesen Polizisten
weil ich muss noch verdauen was du
heranzheimer gesagt hat und ich glaube
genau das ist eine nehme ich das Problem
wenn jemand sagt okay
lass uns doch noch mal reden wird das
kategorisch ausgeschlossen und die
Antwort ist ihr müsst hierher kommen das
leicht sehen darum geht es doch gar
nicht ne also dass das schlimmste ist
kategorisch ausgeschlossen er hat gesagt
sie müssen sie müssen nicht im Studio
sitzen und hier vorbeikommen und das
leidchen also dass das was ich
verstanden habe jetzt am Ende noch er
kann sie jetzt nicht werden konnte ich
auch nicht weil die Pause gegangen sind
aber ich finde das zeigt so ein bisschen
das Problem dass die Fronten sehr
verhärtet sind und und dass da teilweise
argumentativ ja gar nicht mehr
diskutiert wird also es geht um uns leid
uns allen
wenn jetzt jemand sagt ich möchte das
Beenden auf welche Art auch immer
man möchte verhandeln zum Beispiel wenn
man dann sagt sie müssen hierher kommen
und das Leid sehen darum geht's ja nicht
also
wir haben ihn nicht die Frage über
Verhandlungen gestellt und das war
darauf nicht seine Antwort sondern er
hatte generell gesprochen über wenn
jemand der eine Klumpe schreibt oder ein
Spezialist im Studio sitzt äh und sowas
von sich gibt dann müsste er darunter
kommen habe ich tatsächlich schon so
verstanden nee es war auch nicht auf die
verhandlungsfrage aber jetzt da jetzt
können wir darüber auch nicht mit dem
Bett nicht mehr dabei aber ich würde sie
gerne noch aussprechen lassen weil sie
wurden gerade gebrochen eine ganz naive
Frage stellen ich bin
Kulturwissenschaftler und ich kenne mich
auch nicht aus sie sind ja ausgewiesen
Experte wenn also Verhandlungen
definitiv auszuschließen sind wenn wir
Russland nicht weiter die Salami
aufessen und aufschneiden lassen wollen
wie geht es denn weiter also wir hören
erst dann auf wenn Putin also ich frage
mich das wird Putin dann sagen wisst ihr
was okay ich ziehe mich zurück wie wie
geht es denn weiter mal ganz konkret
also die These dass eine macht wie
dieser Russland nicht in einen Krieg
nicht verlieren kann ich weiß nicht
woher diese Erkenntnis kommt also ich
kann mich an den in den letzten zwei
Generationen an mehrere Kriege erinnern
die eine andere atomacht verloren hat
Vietnam afghanist auch der Irak weil
letztlich kein Sieg ja also Atommächte
können Kriege verlieren das ist so und
die Ukraine tut im Moment nichts anderes
sie ist dann ist eine reine
Verteidigungskrieg den die Ukraine führt
denn die Befreiung von besetzten Gebiet
ist selbstverständlich Verteidigung die
auch keine greift da nichts an sondern
sie versucht lediglich Land zu befreien
und vor allen Dingen Menschen zu
befreien die im Moment unter der
Besatzungsmacht Leben und wenn sie sagen
jeden Tag sterben während der
Kampfhandlungen Menschen und durch die
Luftangriffe in den besetzten Gebieten
starben Menschen in Folterkellern
Menschen werden verschleppt also das
Leid wird nicht dadurch auf dass man
einen Waffenstillstand hat sondern die
ethnischen Säuberungen die
rustifizierung mit Gewalt der besetzten
Gebiete die gehen selbstverständlich mit
großen Schritten weiter und dann im
Schutz eines solchen Waffenstillstandes
deswegen dass die Ukraine kämpft das ist
erstens in der Sache legitim und
zweitens ist es auch aussichtsreich und
der Endpunkt nachdem immer gefragt hat
ist natürlich die Befreiung der
Besetzung
mit einem Gebiet jetzt vergleichen was
unmittelbar in Russland
kann kein Krieg verlieren doch
unterwegs ja das wäre doch was ganz
anderes die sind unwegbar dran die
wollten das als Pufferzone ich meine man
muss schon die Dinge irgendwie
geopolitisch bringen oder die wollten
ihr Imperium wieder aufrichten das
wollen Sie immer noch ganz klar
Station macht was sagt die NATO sagt
okay die größte Katastrophe des 20
Jahrhunderts weil der war der Zerfall
der Sowjetunion und seine Politik ist da
aufgerichtet und das Territorium der
Sowjetunion als russisches Gebiet wieder
herzustellen dass er machte an mehreren
Stellen klar gemacht das hat er auch
ganz klar gesagt und er handelt auch
politisch danach das kann man in vielen
Etappen nachweisen in seinem politischen
Werdegang in der Entwicklung seines
politischen Denkens und in den konkreten
Maßnahmen mit denen er das unterlegt das
ist eine sehr konsequent und stringente
Politik wir müssen ihn ernst nehmen ihre
Meinung und wenn wir in ernst nehmen
müssen müssen wir auch seine Drogen
ernst nehmen dass Atomwaffen ein absolut
dieser Ausgangslage
bin ich bisschen anderer